[موسيقى]
المسؤولون الروس من لهجه السخريه من مذكره
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بتوقيف الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وتاييد الغربي لها
وهذا الى لغه غضب وتهديد ففي جلسه بدت
صريحه للغايه مع الصحفيين طالب نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي لمده الصحفيين بان
يتخيلوا معه بحسب تعبيره سيناريو القبض
على الرئيس الروسي ورغم تاكيد ان هذا
التصور لا يتحقق ابدا الا انه دعا
الصحفيين الافتراض حدوثه لافتا انه سيكون
بمثابه اعلان حرب على روسيا
واستكمل المسؤول الروسي قوله بان اعتقال
بوتين سيؤدي بكافه الوسائل الروسيه
للطيران نحو البونستاج والى مكتب المستشار
الالماني واماكن اخرى لم يحددها تصريحاتهم
جاءت ردا على تهديد وزير العدل الالماني
ماركو بوشمان بان برلين ستعتقل بوتين اذا
وصل اراضيها امتثالا لقرار محكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
كان توعد باستهداف لاهاي بصاروخ تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت كردد انتقامي على مذكره
التوقيف التي صدرت بحق بوتين وفقا لوسائل
اعلام هولنديه
وزير العدل الالماني ماركو بوشمان سنلتزم
باعتقال بوتين في حال دخوله المانيا سنسلم
بوتين الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اذا
توجهت المحكمه الجنائيه للشرطه الدوليه
فسابع عشر من مارس 2023 اصدرت المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس
بوتين بدعوى مسؤوليته عن جرائم حرب لكن لا
تمتلك الجنائيه الدوليه سلطه توقيف
المشتبه بهم ايضا سلطاتها تنحصر في الدول
الموقعه على نظام روما الاساسي وروسيا
ليست من بين تلك الدول
ونناقش الموضوع من موسكو مع بسام البنيه
الكاتب السياسي ومنبون عبر سكايب جاسم
محمد رئيس المركز الاوروبي لدراسات مكافحه
الارهاب والاستخبارات مرحبا بكم ضيفي
الكريمين ضيفين من موسكو ابدا معك لماذا
غيرت موسكو من لهجتها حول احتماليه اعتقال
بوتين من السخريه والتهكم الى الذهاب
بالتهديد بضرب المانيا بصاروخ تفوق سرعته
سرعه الصوت
اسال الله مساءك استاذي الكريم ومساء ضيفك
الكريم ومساء مشاهدين قناه العربيه وكل
عام وانتم بخير بمناسبه حلول شهر رمضان
الفضيل كل عام وانت بخير اولا روسيا لم
تغير لهجتها وروسيا لم تغير لهجتها
والكرمن لم تهز له جفن اما تصريح فجاء
لتوصيف حاله بشكل محدد وقال انه افتراضي
الموضوع تخيلوا معي لو كان افتراضي يعني
اي رئيس دوله يريد ان يغادر بلده الى دوله
اخرى هناك بروتوكولات سياسيه وامنيه حتى
مساحه الغرفه واين تقع التي يعيش بها ومن
سيرافق وياخذ ضمانات امنيه فلا لابوت لديه
النيه للذهاب الى المانيا ولا المانيا
لديها نيه بدعوه بوتين الى اليها لذلك انا
اعتقد ان هذا الموضوع يعني فارغ ولا يمكن
لاي سلطه في العالم ان تعتقل بوتين خصوصا
وان اكبر ثلاث دول نوويه في العالم وهم
الصين وروسيا وامريكا لا يعترفوا
كلام كلام فارغ ولكن ولكن كلام متفيد يعني
كلام خطير للغايه في اي اطار يمكن وضع
كلام
استاذي الكريم كلام خطير نعم ولكنه جاء
بعد توصيفه للحاله بانها حاله افتراضيه
يعني نحن نعلم عندما يطير البوتين بطائرته
الرئاسي ترافقها مقاتلات جويه يعني اذا ما
تم اسقاط هذه الطائرات من اجل اجباري على
الهبوط على سبيل المثال هذا يعني اعلان
حرب واذا تم الاعلان الحرب على دوله نوويه
عظمى مثل روسيا هل ستقف متفرجه اذا
اعتقلوا رئيسها المنتخب هل ستقف متفرجيه
بكل تاكيد لا يعني هو يوصف الحاله بشكل
دقيق ولكن هو حدد ان الموضوع افتراضي هذا
لا يعني اننا هنا في روسيا نشعر بخطر
النبوت الممكن ان يعتقله احد لا يمكن لاحد
على وجه هذه الارض اعتقال بوتين الا بعد
ان يرسل دباباته الى الكرملين ويحاصره
ويستطيع الالقاء القبض عليه غير ذلك
الانسان طيب ضيفي من بون استاذ جاسم لنسلم
جدلا بهذه الفرضيه التي افترضها
انه فعلا يتم اعتقال الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين هل اي دوله غربيه صراحه قادره على
تنفيذ امر المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
واعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بالنظر الى قوه هذه الدوله النوويه
انا اشك في قدره الدول اوروبا وكذلك الغرب
في تنفيذ مثل هذا النوع من الاوامر
الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه يذكر
بان المحكمه الجنائيه هي لا تستطيع ان
تنفذ هذا القرار الا بعد ان تطلبه من
الشرطه الدوليه الانتربول بتنفيذ هذا
الامر فاجد انه لحد الان القنوات
الدبلوماسيه هي مفتوحه ما بين دول اوروبا
وخاصه لو تحدثنا عن المانيا وكذلك عن
الدول اوروبا خاصه فرنسا حديث او تعليق
وزير العدل الالباني شومان هو جاء بصراحه
هو من ناحيه قضائيه عندما يكون لديها امر
ممكن ان يكون لكن اجد انه الجميع يتحدث
مثل ما ذكر ضيفك الكريم في باب الفرضيه
لكن لو تحدثنا عنه وضع بوتين
الوزير الالماني لم يكن على سبيل الافتراض
اليس كذلك هو يتحدث
من ناحيه قانونيه انه لو وطت قدم بوتين في
المانيا فهو كوزير عدل من حقه ان يقوم
بالتنفيذ امر الشرطه الدوليه بالقاء القبر
وكذلك المستشار الالماني رحب في الخطوه
التي صدرت من المحكمه الجنائيه اذا لو
تحدثنا قضائيا بعيد عن السياسه انه كل
الامور او كل كل
الاوامر القضائيه هي لا تكون في صالح
روسيا او صالح بوتر لكن هنا احب ان اوضح
ان هذا يعني القرار الصادر من المحكمه
الجنائيه هو يضع دول اوروبا في وضع حرج
اكثر مما يؤثر على روسيا كون ان هذا
القرار هذا يعني يعني انه لا توجد مستقبلا
اي قنوات اتصال وحوار كيف يوضع الرئيس
بوتين بانه مطلوبه في جرائم حرب ويقوم
الاتصال به من قبل الزعماء دول اوروبا على
سبيل المثال لو تحدثنا عن المانيا وكذلك
فرنسا هنالك قواعد او قنوات بصراحه
متواصله فاذا تجد المحكمه الجنائيه
اخذتها من ناحيه قضائيه ولكن اجد انه دول
اوروبا ممكن في اطار القانون في اطار
القضاء استاذ بسام البني في موسكو هل لهذا
السبب يعني بدات روسيا تستشعر انه يمكن
والله الغربيين لديهم جديه انه في النهايه
هي دول تطبق القانون وبالتالي فعلا يمكن
ان تمتثل وتطبق قرار المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ولذلك صعدت من لهجتها هذه المره
على لسان وغيرت نبره السخريه والتهكم على
قرار متابعه الرئيس الروسي بجرائم حرب
لا يعني روسيا تعتبر ان الاوروبيين لا
ينفذون القانون فهم يعتمدون على الملكيات
الشخصيه ويعتدون على المظاهر المتظاهرين
في فرنسا بالعروات وبالغاز المسيل للدموع
والى اخره ويعتقلون الناس يعني روسيا
تعتبر الاوروبيين مستعمره امريكيه ان صح
التعبير موجودين تحت الاحتلال الامريكي
وينفذون ما يريدونه الامريكي واريد ان
انوه هنا ان مذكره اعتقال بوتين ليست
مذكره جنائيه راينا الدفاع واين الدلائل
واين كل هذه النقاط هي قرار سياسي بامتياز
تم بضغط من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
على الدول
واذكر هنا اين كريم
على ما اعتقد اسم القاضي الذي اصدر المدعي
العام الذي اصدر هذه المذكره كان متهما
اخير منذ ثلاث اسابيع بقضيه اغتصاب طفل
فتم بعدها اخلاء سبيله وبعد ان اخلو سبيله
بثلاث اسابيع تم اصدارها هذه المذكره وهو
قال ان اصدار المذكره هذا يعني
من المؤسف ولكن يجب على القانون ان ينفذ
يعني هو مبتز بشكل كامل اضف الى ذلك ان
هذا القرار لا يمكن تنفيذه على الاطلاق
فلم يسلم اي رئيس دوله سوى بعد ان هزمت
وبعد ان خرج من الحكم اما بوتين فهو على
راس السلطه الحكم وهو رئيس منتخب وهو رئيس
دوله عظمى لم تهزم فكيف يمكن لاحد ان يجرؤ
على اعتقالي لا لا اعتقد ان احدا سيجرؤ
على اعتقادي حتى لو كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بنفسها وهي بالمناسبه لا تعترف
به جاسم محمد يعني هذه المناوشات وهذه
التصريحات التي يعلو سقفها في كل مره ما
بين روسيا والدول الغربيه يعني هي كثرت في
الفتره الماضيه والحديث عن التلويح
السلاح النووي او الحرب النوويه بالامس
كانت مساله صواريخ اليورانيوم المستنفذ
التي ترسلها المانيا بريطانيا عفوا الى
اوكرانيا
روسيا هددت كذلك بارسال اليورانيوم حقيقي
الى بيلاروسيا
الان الحديث عن امكانيه ضرب اي دوله غربيه
تقوم باعتقال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين كل
هذه التصريحات وتصاعدها هل ينبئ فعلا على
ان المواجهه وشيكا اننا بالفعل مقبلون على
حرب عالميه ام هذه فقط تبقى في اطار
المناوشات يعني والتصعيد والحرب الكلاميه
فقط
التصعيد اصبح اكثر من السابق ولذلك نلاحظ
نستطيع القول بان الحرب الفعل انتقلت الى
صفحه جديده اجد انهما صرحت به بريطانيا
بان تكون هنالك صواريخ ذات يورانيوم
المنظم هذا بصراحه يعتبر خطوه استفزازيه
من قبل بريطانيا ونلاحظ انه المواقف
البريطانيه منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا هي
رئيس حربه وربما هذا يعود الى الحرب
البارده وتراكمات تاريخيه ما بين بريطانيا
وكذلك
يعني روسيا فاذا هنالك مبدا وهو قواعد
الاشتباك عندما يكون هنالك قواعد اشتباك
متفق عليها ما بين الناتو هو روسيا هذا
يعني نحن ممكن ان نتجنب الحرب وعندما
نتحدث عن الردع والردع المضاد خاصه في
المجال النووي هنالك ايضا قواعد تعتمد من
قبل روسيا وكذلك الناتو فيجد انه لحد الان
صرح ان وروسيا بانهم ليس في وارد الانخراط
في هذه الحرب لكن المشهد الان هو تصعيد
لكن اجد في النهايه انه لن يتوفي وارد
الدخول في حرب عالميه وكذلك روسيا استاذ
بسام البني هل توافق الاستاذ جاسم بان
يعني قواعد الاشتباك ما بين روسيا والغرب
ما تزالت ما تزال على حالها عدم الذهاب
بالفعل الى حرب كبرى عالميه فقط ضمن
التصريحات الكلاميه وقواعد الاشتباك
الحاليه
يعني اوافق على قواعد الاشتباك لان بعد ان
اسقطت روسيا طائره الدرون فوق البحر
الاسود التي اخترقت الاجواء الروسيه او
كانت تنميه اختراق الاجواء الروسيه تم
التصريح من قبل بلينكن انه اتصل بالخارجيه
وتمت تصريح ان وزير الدفاع اتصل بوزير
الدفاع الروسي من اجل مناقشه هذا الامر
وطول الامر ولكن انا الاحظ ان التصعيد
مستمر فعلا وقد يذهب فينا الى حرب عالميه
ثالثه بين مباشره بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والناتو من جهه وروسيا من جهه
اخرى لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عادت
بعد هذه الحادثه وقالت انها سترسل هذه
الطائرات فوق البحر الاسود غير عابئه بما
قررته روسيا بفرض منطقه حظر جوي مؤقته من
اجل العمليه العسكريه وهذه الطائره تجمع
المعلومات وتقدم لاوكرانيا اذا امريكا
تحدى روسيا بانها ستخترق ما قررته روسيا
بعدم هذه الاجواء فماذا سيكون في المستقبل
هل ستقوم روسيا باسقاط هذه الطائرات اذا
ما تم اسقاطها ماذا سيكون الرد الامريكي
هل ترد مثلا بضرب موقع روسي بشكل مباشر
هنا الخطوره الخطوره تكمن ليس بعدم وجود
وسائط الاتصال من عدمها وانما
بالتصرفات الفعليه على الارض روسيا تقول
لا اريد حرب عالميه ثالثه وهم يقولون لا
نريد ان نشترك مع روسيا ولكن تصرفاتهم تدل
على انهم غير ابيهين بالاراده الروسيه
بعدم السماح لهم بتهديد ابناء القومي هذا
يعني اننا قد نشهد بالفعل حرب مباشره شكرا
جزيلا لكما ضيفي الكريمين بسام البني
الكتب السياسي من موسكو وجاسم محمد رئيس
المركز الاوروبي لدراسات المكافحه الارهاب
والاستخبارات من بورن